ein gang durch die welt der sprechende
hüllen oder tiger lilly lange nicht
gesehen stimmt meine lady hat gerade die
krise da hilft nur der mega stücke nach
und meiner poliert sein ego neuerdings
mit roten socken hoffentlich sozial
peinlich er will sich von an herrn roth
angebot ausgerechnet heute wo sie sich
so unsicher fühlen sich unsicher ist
betten ständer bestimmt nicht
stilsicherheit gehört zum job
die kuratorin der ausstellung fashion
torx weiß dass kleider mehr sagen als
uns lieb ist
also das was wir an haben und ob wir uns
bewusst sind oder nicht ordnen wir den
anderen das gegenüber natürlich mit
anhand von kleidung ein kleiner
kommunizieren und kleider machen leute
diese weisheit gilt noch immer auch bei
der museumsbesuche rinnen und besucher
wie kleider beeinflussen zeigt auch ein
ampel teste durch verschiedene studien
belegt ist menschen in business anzügen
genießen dabei ein besonders hohes
vertrauen sagte handel auf not wird dem
geschäftsmann ohne zu zögern gefolgt
geht der selbe mann im schlabberhosen
blog bei rot über die straße zeigt sich
ein anderes bild
er wird kritisch beäugt manchmal wird
der business-anzug jedoch auch zur qual
und die bunte einfallslosigkeit zur
pflicht kanzlerin merkel wollte nur
einmal individualität zeigen
doch das ging gehörig schief die presse
schlug alarm
merkel dekolleté affäre ist dass sich
das auf einmal ein kleidungsstück
politisch wird oder beziehungsweise eine
frau mit dekolleté politisch wird und
niemand spricht eigentlich davon ob eine
krawatte zu groß oder zu bunt oder zu
grün ist bei den jugendlichen hingegen
gehört ein bisschen provokation als mode
ist hier abgrenzung military fashion und
camouflage bekleidung haben auch heute
noch einen besonderen reiz
kuratorin ihrer franke weiß dass die
entstehungsgeschichte dieser designs
überraschendes bietet ende des ersten
weltkriegs von künstlern eigentlich in
die militärische nutzung gebracht sie
waren die ersten die diese muster gemalt
haben und erst danach ist richtig breit
eingesetzt worden zu militärischen
zwecken
für manche ist mode auch eine andere
form von kunst
jedenfalls gibt sie uns die möglichkeit
unsere ur eigene kreativität auszuleben
wenn wir uns trauen
flammen
werde